what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I believe I am finally over my
flu
thank God dude this thing was such a
hassle to have yeah god I hate this loop
anyway um so we are on to infinity
countdown now for those you guys who
don't know infinity countdown is the big
lead-up event that Marvel's doing to
their infinity story and it's kind of
funny because Marvel was like no new
events for eighteen hundred months but I
mean nobody everybody new Marvel wasn't
gonna be able to stick to that
especially was something as big as
infinity war Marvel is definitely gonna
have to find a way to like tap into that
but one of things we covered in
guardians of the galaxy which is really
why we covered that story is because
that saw the return of Adam warlock now
for the most part the return of Adam
warlock was maybe two pages two or three
pages in that story in the sense that
you had the main audiences the galaxy
story going on and then Adam warlock was
basically kind of yanked from soul world
and just ended up in in the main Marvel
Universe and he had been brought forward
by Kang the Conqueror now what this does
is it kind of shines light on a few
different things one of the first things
that I want to talk about here is the
nature of Adam warlock and the role he
played with regards to jim Starlin
versus what's going on right here in
recent weeks probably within the last
month or so jim Starlin it kind of been
hosted for Marvel he had basically you
know either been forced to leave or left
but regardless of the of the motivation
as to why he's not with the company
anymore but one of the last stories that
he wrote came after all-new
all-different marvel and it was infinity
finale and what infinity finale did is
it established that Adam warlock is the
New Living Tribunal now the weird thing
about this is that Marvel's you know one
of their guys or one of their top guys
Tom Brevoort said well that story's not
really in continuity but it doesn't
really make any sense because a Living
Tribunal is designed to be a multiversal
entity if it is a story that takes place
in a defined space with planets and
stars and so on and so forth it's a
story that takes place in the universe
if it's a story that takes place in the
universe it's part of the multiverse and
the Living Tribunal is not bound by any
one universe The Living Tribunal is a
multiversal entity ergo if Adam warlock
became the more the Lavi tribunal in one
universe then he is the definitive
living tribunal throughout the
multiverse so I mean that's that's
that's one of the reasons why it doesn't
really make sense but Marvel says that's
not true so I guess we kind of have to
go with it hey even then with this story
they don't really draw on that they
don't really kind of say well yeah I
mean you know you're the living tribe
you know but like you're also here that
was an alternate reality version of Adam
so that could still work he could still
make it fit but the whole idea here is
that Adam warlock returning came from
Sol world and Sol world as we talked
about it
Adam warlock explained video it was
really part and parcel to Adam himself
in the sense of the soul stone was
introduced to Marvel Comics in the
original Roy Thomas Adam warlock era
when it was basically you know Adam
becoming kind of like a christ-like
figure and basically being given the
soul Jim by like the High Evolutionary
but the idea was that when jim Starlin
to go with a character when he started
expanding on the Marvel cosmology the
overall gist was to say that the souls
of the soul Jim houses soul world it's
an actual pocket dimension that's one of
reasons why I say and black panther the
Panther God bast will probably be in
Soul world or at least that's how Black
Panther will communicate with all the
former Black Panthers is by using the
soul stone but regardless the soul stone
has a soul world and one of the things
that started established is that the
soul Jim unlike the other infinity gems
it has the ability to basically steal
people's souls if they don't keep
themselves weary if they're not able to
maintain control over the stone itself
and so because of the fact that Adam
warlock was in possession of the stone
for so long because of the fact that he
had to basically find a way to get the
stone from taking his soul as well as
taking the spirits of like gomorrah and
pit the troll and light rocks a
destroyer and whisking them off to soul
world when their physical bodies had
died he'd effectively become part and
parcel to the soul Jim itself and so it
was as much of a part of his body as his
arms and legs and head torso and whole
nine yards and so because that the soul
Jim and Adam warlock have always gone
hand in hand at least as far as Jim
Stalin's riding has been concerned and
so with that in mind with Cain the
conquer waking up Adam warlock or at
least kind of bringing him to the
indication here seems to be twofold it
seems to be that out of warlock you know
just kind of came out of his cocoon by
his own volition and that's one of the
things is kind of hit home here regards
to this whole discussion that takes
place between Cain the Conqueror and
Adam warlock a king really kind of gives
us as the reader a tour of Adam warlocks
life now if those are guys who have seen
my videos on Adam warlock explain this
is all familiar territory to you and in
truth will be retraining water but for
the new folks this is the life and times
of Adam warlock spread over the course
of two pages that's really about it Adam
warlock was created by a group called
the Enclave they wanted to basically
find a way to conquer the world they
created the perfect artificial being
ultimately Adam warlock turned against
them and alongside the Fantastic Four
defeated the Enclave and then took off
into space once that happened he
actually tried to take SIF as his bride
came into conflict with Thor Thor
defeated him Adam warlock retreated yet
again you know and then of course he was
basically brought back by the High
Evolutionary
he was given the soul
he was sent to counter-earth which was
just an opposite version of earth
defeated man-beast
went back into his cocoon I mean this is
the kind of process that was repeated
over and over and over again the point
where you see the involvement of Thanos
that's when jim Starlin started taking
over that's when jim Starlin had like
this second or i guess the first return
of Thanos and he allied himself with
Adam warlock all the while plotting and
scheming to steal the Infinity stones
for the first time that Thanos would
possess them which at the end of that
story he was turned into a giant piece
of giant piece of stone but that's the
way that says this it's basically this
amazing you know summed up life and
times of Adam warlock within two pages
he's fought alongside the Avengers he's
defeated Thanos he was there during
Infinity Gauntlet so on and so forth you
know but the idea here is it really does
again hit on the nature of soul world
that the souls of individuals who have
possessed the soul stone but had their
souls taken reside within soul world now
for the most part it's a place of peace
you know that's one of the reasons why
I'm Adam warlock always had this kind of
Zen concept about him because it was
like you know he kind of hung out in
Soul world and I don't know I guess they
drink tea and smoke weed all day long I
have no idea what they did and then when
they were in there but they just kind of
they just kind of hung out and they just
chilled but remember this is Cain the
conqueror now for those of you guys who
don't know what that means
Cain the Conqueror is one of those weird
characters that Marvel kind of messes
with over the years when it comes to
time travel
traditionally in Marvel Comics we're
gonna keep this super simple we're not
gonna go into a huge in-depth thing but
when it comes to time travel but let's
say for example that Wolverine like old
man Logan travels into the future and
meets his future self for the most part
they're two distinctly different beings
there's the old you know I guess the
younger version of old man Logan before
you know in the past and then there's
the older version of old man Logan in
the future but they've they've had
experiences in between these two periods
that led them to become distinctly
different beings now a lot of this will
turn into something you know worse like
I can't tell you what's gonna happen you
know for fear of ruining the future or
something along those lines but Kane the
Conqueror is much the same way just on a
much grander scale the idea is you've
got you know really really old Kane the
Conqueror from way back in the day you
know back in the age of age of Egypt and
then you've got different versions of
Cana conquer along the way and then
you've got future Kane the Conqueror but
the idea is that they're all time
travelers of some former fashion they
all stem from the future Kane the
Conqueror and so the idea is that he's
jumped back in time at multiple points
and effectively created versions of
himself and that's why you'll see like
five or six or seven different versions
of K in the Conqueror each of who
are completely different some of whom
don't want to become that future version
and some of whom do it gets really weird
and it gets really wild and it's one of
those characters and I kind of wish
Marvel would just reconcile it all
already
and just kind of make sense of it all as
opposed to just kind of leaving him out
there as a wildly confusing character
but the fact remains here came the
conquer is invoked in this story because
he's basically a guy who resides at the
end of time the moment before all things
and in the Marvel multiverse and so
because of that he basically knows or at
least seems to have an indication of
everything that's going to happen now
that's one of the weird things is Marvel
kind of teases the idea that the future
set in stone but it's not set in stone
you know it's what else things were like
this guaranteed future is going to
happen until someone stops it and then
it's not a guaranteed future so now the
future is kind of blank and something
else will happen until somebody stops
that or allows it to happen and so
because of the fact that Kang is kind of
in this place where he's at the end of
all things when he looks at the past
when he looks at time it's kind of a
swirling mishmash of things that shift
and move and change constantly because
things in the past are influencing his
quote-unquote present what we would call
the future so that's why it's so weird
that's why Kane the Conqueror is so
mind-bending and mind-boggling basically
is this idea that people in the past are
changing things and so Kane the
Conqueror can't get an actual grip on
what's supposed to happen in the future
all he knows is that somewhere along the
line someone is going to gain the
Infinity stones are gonna bring all the
Infinity stones together and when they
do basically all the earth superheroes
are going to die so in a lot of ways
it's kind of a repeat of the events of
the original Infinity Gauntlet story but
on a much bigger scale and that's one of
the things a lot of people seem to lose
track of the the story infinity war was
by all standards of definition much
larger than the events of Infinity
Gauntlet Infinity Gauntlet had a lot of
cosmic entities and the stakes were
higher should you know the superheroes
have failed but the idea who is that
when it came to the Infinity Gauntlet
story in terms of the number of Earth's
superheroes who were fighting against
Thanos it was about a dozen maybe a
little bit more and infinity war it was
all the superheroes it was a Fantastic
Four the x-men x-factor the Avengers the
whole nine yards everybody was involved
in that story it was a huge event but
the general gist remains the same
somebody's gathering the Infinity stones
and somebody's going to use them to take
out Earth's superheroes now we don't
know exactly how this fits together we
don't know what the first blow is we
don't know if Thanos is gathering the
Infinity stones and they all attack him
and it's a repeat of Infinity Gauntlet
we don't even know if it's
warlock himself we're just kind of left
to sort of figure this out on our own or
the very least to give us a little bit
of a taste so that as the events are
revealed when they go further into
infinity countdown leading up to this
huge summer infinity event then we'll
all start to make sense but the idea of
khang is go into the distant past
you know travel back to the early days
of Egypt find a version of find this
this you know older version of myself or
this younger version of myself really I
know he'll tell you everything you need
to know and so this is kind of
interesting here because Marvel's done
this on a couple of occasions this point
in time when Adam warlock travels back
to the early days this is back when King
became Rama Tut hisses back when he was
ruling over Egypt but the idea here is
that with Adam warlock speaking directly
to this version of King speaking to Rama
Tut as well go ahead and call him is
essentially this instance of Rama Todd
has has essentially been talking to his
future self they're talking to Cain and
they've been exchanging notes and all
King would really tell him is you need
to make sure Adam warlock gets to where
he needs to go that he gets towards this
future the problem with this is that
walk hang is a time traveler he is also
wanting to make sure that he has the
means to travel back to his future if he
needs to so it's kind of making sure
that Adam warlock can't really take his
his time travel abilities so to speak as
though when he is up doing is basically
saying what you have to do is you have
to get to that star over there but you
need to basically wait for a point in
time whereby you can traverse the
spaceways when your energy is stored up
enough and get out to where it is that
you need to go but the reason why you
have to get to that star is because you
have to find the soul stone and the
reason why you have to find the soul
stone is because one you're intertwined
with it and two the person in possession
of it is the Magus now the Magus is a
version of Adam warlock from an
alternate future and the idea when the
story was being told you know back in
the day by Jim stone and I'm pretty sure
it was it was basically this idea that
Adam warlock because of his exposure to
the soul stone would eventually become
like a despot
would eventually he would just kind of
go crazy and become like a terrible
totalitarian dictator but it would all
be predicated on a theater a theological
basis meaning he would go on to form a
group called the universal Church of
truth and the universal Church of truth
would span thousands and thousands of
systems with billions of people in
different alien races who would all be
part of it but Adam warlock I guess the
Magus would use this as a means to
basically solidify power and control and
so this brought Adam warlock directly
into conflict with an alternate reality
version of himself and then he
effectively engineered circumstances so
the Magus could never truly exist
now this segue directly into the events
of infinity war so that when Infinity
Gauntlet ended and Adam warlock
basically took the Infinity Gauntlet
he brought the Magus back and well wait
until we cover you know infinity war to
explain why because you find out like
two issues in so it's not like a great
big huge ending reveal for the story or
anything like that but the idea is that
because you know Rama Todd doesn't just
want to like give away his time travel
technology what he ends up doing is
grabbing out a warlock and throwing him
into a kind of stasis of sorts basically
filling him inside of a tomb and just
sort of keeping him there you know it's
kind of keeping him confined to this
space now Adam warlock being disabled is
the only reason why he's not able to
make his escape give me the power that
he has you know if it got to a point
where he came to you he would easily be
able to break himself out but came to
conquer having the kind of abilities and
technology that he has can easily subdue
Adam warlock but it's basically saying
hey look because there's somebody out
there that has the time stone because
there's somebody out there that has this
particular artifact what it means is
that if I put you in a time machine and
I send you forward in time and I say hey
yo man head on out there they'll
immediately know what it is that you're
doing and they'll stop you along the way
they'll basically block you in your
tracks and they could send you idiot
we're in time they could send you into
the far distant future half a second
before the multiverse ends they could
send you into the very you know
beginnings of the universe when the Big
Bang first happens and all life comes
into existence so you've got to wait
billions of years to get to the current
point by which your body will most
likely just burn out and die the only
way to basically allow Adam warlock to
travel to 2018 this moment right now in
order to essentially access whoever it
is and has a soul stone access to Magus
it's to literally heaven time travel the
organic way have a time travel the only
normal way to effectively throw him into
a tomb and leave him there for however
many thousands of years so that when he
re-emerged he'll be in the modern day
and he'll be able to join the guardians
or whoever in track down the Magus and
effectively take the Infinity stone back
now that of course brings a question why
didn't you know Kane the Conqueror just
7:00 or 2018 in the first place I don't
really know I assume it was just for the
sake of being able to tell a story I'm
not really sure but what this does do is
assess Adam warlock on the path one it
brings him back and it sets him on the
path of going after his all you know
alternate future self going after the
Magus and essentially setting the stage
for the idea of him basically getting
back the soul stone and returning to the
position of Adam warlock as we most
commonly know him but without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here two comments
explain it make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
cork if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you